-Donald Trump stormed out
of Manhattan courtroom
after he was called
to the witness stand
and reprimanded by a judge
for violating a gag order.
And yet, Trump's legal woes
have not tempered
the Republican Party's
ongoing devotion to him,
as evidenced by their latest
choice for speaker Mike Johnson,
a right-wing hardliner
who helped engineer
Trump's attempts to overturn
the 2020 election.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
We are all used
to the screaming,
blustery Trump
we see at rallies,
constantly ranting about
everything from
windmills killing birds
and whales
to toilets that don't flush
to various celebrities
who either are or are not
nasty to him.
That Trump is everywhere,
and it gets dumber every day,
like on Monday at a rally
in New Hampshire
when he claimed to have
had an epiphany.
-I'm for us.
I'm for us.
You know how you
spell "us," right?
You spell "us" U-S.
I just picked that up.
Has anyone ever thought
of that before?
I just picked that up
a couple of days --
I'm reading and it said "us,"
and I said, you know,
if you think about it,
"us" equals U-S.
-Okay, so the bad news is,
the Republican frontrunner for
the 2024 presidential nomination
is out here
designing pillows for TJ Maxx.
The dude is dumb as dumb rocks.
But the good news is
he would crush
a two-letter word spelling bee.
"Your word is 'me.'"
"Can you use it
in a sentence, please?"
"You have got to be
[bleep] kidding me."
If I had come home from school
as a seven-year-old
and told my parents,
"Did you know 'us'
is spelled U and S?"
my parents would have
immediately called the school
and said, "I think we need
to make the curriculum
a little more challenging."
Well, my dad would have.
My mom would have
called me a genius
and baked me a cake.
But here's here's what's least
believable about that clip.
-A couple of days,
I'm reading and it said "us."
-No, you weren't reading.
You don't read.
You know how I know
you don't read?
If you did, you wouldn't have
discovered at age 77
that "us" is spelled
with a U and an S.
I mean, what have
you have been reading anyway
that would have spurred
such an epiphany?
"Chicka Chicka Boom Boom"?
"A told B and B told C,
I'll meet you at the top
of the coconut tree.
But it's too late.
I already chopped down the tree.
And I replaced it with
a Trump resort!
There won't be any trees,
but there will be
plenty of coconuts,
if you know what I mean.
That kid's shaking his head no.
He doesn't know what I mean."
-So that's the blustery,
unhinged, public Trump.
But then there's the Trump
you don't get to see,
and that's the Trump who only
exists when he's under oath.
And when he's under oath,
he's under penalty of perjury.
He's suddenly much calmer.
He's more restrained.
You could even say sheepish.
Here he is, for example,
in a deposition from 2016
related to a restaurant that
pulled out of his D.C. hotel.
-Good morning, Mr. Trump.
And again, thank you very much
for being here.
-Thank you.
-Would you state your full name
for the record, please?
-Donald John Trump.
-And I imagine you've had
your deposition taken
a number of times?
-I have, yes.
-So you know the drill.
-I do.
-I won't waste anyone's time
going through it.
-Good. Thank you.
-Do know that
if you need to take a break,
I'm happy to let you.
-Very good.
Thank you.
-My understanding is that
you signed this lease.
And if you look at page --
-That's true.
He asked me, yeah.
-Okay.
-Well, I did --
I believe I signed the lease,
but he came in and said,
"We're signing the lease."
I'll change it, yes.
-He said, "We're signing it"?
-Because I think I signed it.
Yeah. That's my signature. Yes.
-"Yes, that's -- that's my name.
And in fact,
I'm just picking this up now --
D and O together spells do.'
So really, my name
should be Do-nald.
If you think --
If you think about that."
That footage is amazing.
It's like watching
the neighborhood Rottweiler
who's always
terrorizing the mailman
suddenly mope around in a cone.
Like, in public
he's a raving lunatic,
screaming [bleep] like,
"Radical woke Democrats
are using windmills and secret
satellites to kill Christmas."
And then, under oath,
he's practically Emily Post.
"Thank you.
No, thank you very much.
I would love to read
some incriminating documents.
Thank you."
Because that's the only place
Trump faces consequences.
That's the one way
you can still punish Trump,
make him sit down
in a courtroom
and answer questions under oath
with his tail between his legs.
And that's what happened
yesterday, when the judge
in his civil fraud trial hauled
him up to the witness stand
to reprimand him
for violating a gag order
that bars Trump
from attacking court staff.
-Donald Trump,
taking the stand today
in his civil fraud trial
in New York
after being ordered by the judge
to testify about comments
he made regarding a court clerk.
Trump claimed that
he wasn't talking about
the person
sitting next to the judge.
He was actually talking
about Michael Cohen,
who at the time,
was in the middle of
his second day of testimony,
not the clerk.
Judge Engoron was not buying it,
not for a nanosecond,
and he swiftly fined
Donald Trump $10,000
and rebuked Trump.
-So Trump was ordered to take
the stand and explain himself,
and then the judge said,
"I don't believe you,"
and reprimanded him.
I can only imagine
what that looked like.
He was probably like
a middle schooler
who refuses to look
his parent in the eye
after cursing them out.
"What did you just say?"
"Nothing."
"Tell me what you said."
"I said F you."
"Look at me when you say it."
"I said F you, okay?
It's not a curse word.
I was talking about my favorite
band, the Foo Fighters.
I was reading
and I just picked that up."
In fact, we don't have video or
photos of this historic moment,
but we do have a courtroom
sketch, and it's amazing.
Even in a courtroom sketch,
Trump is making a face like
he just realized
he's in trouble --
mouth slightly open, looking
at the judge like, "Uhhh."
Also, whoever drew this did
Trump some huge favors,
because this looks like
a "New Yorker" cartoon,
where in reality
he's much more of a "Cathy."
And then,
like a pissy teenager,
Trump made things
even more dramatic
by storming out of the courtroom
less than an hour later.
-This was a dramatic
turn of events, Lester.
Former President Trump stormed
out of a Manhattan courtroom
after a tense day
after the judge
refused his attorney's request
to dismiss the case.
-Michael Cohen
did resume testifying,
but Trump didn't stick around
to hear him finish,
the disgraced ex-president,
storming out of the courtroom
with Secret Service agents
left to chase after him.
-Okay, "chase"
seems like a strong word.
They chased him the way
you chased your pet turtle
in the yard.
"He's going that way."
[ Laughter ]
I'm sure Secret Service
didn't have to run too hard.
They probably saw him take off
and said, "He's on the move.
Should we finish this game of
Monopoly and then go catch up?"
"But we haven't even started."
"We'll be fine."
We're talking about a guy
who moves slower than a zombie
after a giant bong rip.
-"You know what's a funny word?
Brains."
And then, just to give you
an idea of how defeated
Trump was after all that,
when he left the courtroom,
he gave the press a one-sentence
answer then walked away.
-That wasn't even
one of his good lies.
The witness, Michael Cohen,
admitted Trump won the trial?
You know
there are transcripts right?
That lady isn't writing
in her diary.
Trump having to take the stand
and actually talk to the judge
clearly spun him out.
-"The witness said we won,
and the judge agreed and
apologized for the whole deal.
And I'm so [bleep], you guys.
I'm so [bleep].
They made me
sit next to the judge.
That can't be good, right?"
And yet, the Republican Party
nonetheless remains in thrall
to a man who just got scolded
by a judge
in a courtroom
during a fraud trial,
as evidenced by the fact
that they just elected a guy
named Mike Johnson from
Louisiana as their new speaker.
Johnson isn't just
an election denier.
He was, according
to the "New York Times,"
"the most important architect
of the Electoral College
objections on January 6th."
And he's not just a guy who
thinks there was election fraud,
which would be wrong on its own,
he parroted the most bat[bleep]
crazy conspiracy theories
you can imagine.
Remember Trump's ex-lawyer
Sidney Powell,
who just flipped
on him in Georgia?
Remember how she didn't just say
the usual GOP stuff
like "mail voting isn't secure,"
but went way off the deep end
and claimed the Dominion
voting software was rigged
by the dead Venezuelan President
Hugo Chavez?
-The Dominion Voting systems,
the Smartmatic
technology software,
and the software that goes
in other computerized
voting systems here as well,
not just Dominion,
were created in Venezuela
at the direction of Hugo Chavez
to make sure
he never lost an election.
-Now, we have played this clip
a few times lately,
because Powell just pleaded
guilty in Georgia,
and every time, it's impossible
not to be distracted
by Rudy Giuliani behind her,
sweating profusely
and trying to unscrew the cap
from a tiny water bottle
like it has the antidote inside.
I think he's sweating because
he can't open the water bottle,
like it's slowly dawning
on him that
if he can't get
the cap off a Fiji bottle,
he might not be a good lawyer.
"Oh boy, this is a bad sign.
But when it's my turn
at the mic,
I'm going to blow them away or
my name's not Ruby Gugliotta."
Anyway, that was the insane
conspiracy theory that,
among other things, Fox News had
to pay nearly $800 million for
in a defamation suit.
And yet Mike Johnson,
the new Speaker of the House,
actually thought
those claims had merit,
as he said in a radio interview
at the time.
-"And I'll tell you another
thing, I agree with Rudy.
Those water bottles
are hard to open."
That's how nuts this guy is.
He's just as crazy as Trump.
It's just a style difference.
Trump is Jigsaw
and Johnson is Dexter.
He agreed with the lunatic
who just pleaded guilty
to crimes in Georgia
and repeated talking points
that caused Fox News
to pay out $800 million
to settle a defamation case.
He just says stuff in a normal,
mild-mannered, moderate voice
the Republicans think will
make him easier to stomach.
He's the kind of guy
who would curse you out,
but instead of saying
the words "you [bleep],"
he'd say --
-U-S.
-Didn't see it coming.
Didn't see it coming.
This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪